you guys remember that time when ty
burrell that one's great
oh my god
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show without
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Emmy Award winning
actor Ty Burrell you know miss Phil
Dunphy on ABC's mega hit Modern Family
now in its ninth season and you can
catch them on mouths feelings a podcast
where they talk about the things that go
into your mouth and the feelings that
come out of it it's a great tagline it's
great to have you in the seat ty welcome
to the show thank you I appreciate it
I'm very very very scared do you know
what you're getting yourself into
I feel like everything I'm saying is
gonna be famous last words but I love
hot food I don't really have a very
subtle palette
mmm like I don't know I'm eating
something unless it's hot
[Music]
yes wouldn't be great if I checked out
right now
like a mother so you got your big break
as an actor a little bit later in life
which left plenty of room for some odd
offbeat jobs when you were working as a
forest fire fighter did you ever get a
call that made you fear for your life
fire made me fear for my life
I was a terrible firefighter I was soft
as cotton candy and had no business
being a forest fighter fighter
actually the very first call we ever got
was a semi with its gas tank on fire
well he was a two-man crew Oregons not a
big steak he was pushing us closer to
the fire and I was pushing us away from
the fire and we formed a sort of a
teepee we were having a reverse
tug-of-war on the hose and it was bigger
and I won and we ended up going very
very far away from the fire and tried to
try just pray from like 50 yards away it
was more like this
[Music]
how many of these do you do a week you
know we go weekly so okay if we bank a
bunch of episodes then I'll have a chill
couple weeks but if that gas tank runs
low then I have to just start stacking
them like I know this yesterday mm-hmm
there's when people are attacking let's
get to the stacking it's really the
cross that I bear you know it's the
grave that I've dug to myself oh this is
a girl's drawing I appreciate you saying
though so the internet seems fascinated
with fills ah Sophie and then you've
talked in the past about how sometimes
the storylines and Modern Family can
mirror your experience as a real-life
father so with that in mind what I want
to do is bounce some quotes off of you
from other iconic TV dads I'm curious if
you think it's good parenting advice or
bad parenting advice I'm a terrible
person to ask about parenting advice but
let's see how it goes yeah let's do it
this first one is from Homer Simpson
counseling Lisa if you don't like your
job you don't strike you just go in
every day and do it really half-assed
that's the American Way it is the
American Way
I guess it's I mean it's Homer Simpson
it has to be good advice this next one
is from Uncle Phil off Fresh Prince of
bel-air to be a good friend you have to
risk losing a good friend I would agree
with that but I am so afraid of conflict
but I don't know that I've ever
challenged any of my good friends so I
don't know if I can live up to that but
I would agree with it in theory you
don't necessarily have to be that person
to dish out the game right that's right
exactly I'd like to do as I say and not
as I do
and then this last one is from Phil
Dunphy the most amazing things that can
happen to a human being will happen to
you if you just lower your expectations
I've loved that many levels lowest
expectation levels where are your
expectations today my expectation today
is that it's gonna hurt and tomorrow
we're just
[Music]
from the Bronx I take it from the BX so
as we alluded to in your intro you host
of food focused podcast and then your
wife Holly I know that she's a pastry
chef you know how if at all has she
changed your perspective on food because
you've described yourself as a lawless
animal when it comes to eating we
couldn't be any more different the
upside of having the palate of a goat is
that everything she makes is great and
then I know that you own a pair of bars
in Salt Lake City what was the biggest
hurdle you had to overcome and securing
a liquor license because from what I
understand there's some strange rules
and YouTube yeah well they've actually
gotten better back in the day you have
to do all kinds of crazy things if you
go all the way back a drink couldn't be
made in a bar so they would actually
give you like the airline bottle and the
mixer and you do it yourself do it
yourself then they have memberships or
you had to kind of become a member to
get into a club so everybody who walked
into a bar had to become a member that
went away it's very hard to get a liquor
license that in and of itself is very
hard somebody smarter than me found that
a literal loophole which is that if you
if there's a hole in the wall or a
doorway the place next to you gets her
liquor license
so we leased the space next to us and
cut a hole in the wall and there you go
Inessa and then for the uninitiated can
you explain the allure of fry sauce well
fry sauce is mayonnaise and ketchup so
that's all it is it sounds a lot more
exotic than it is that's right
[Music]
it's really good it is really good
thank you ever handin yeah yeah we you
know like we had the lab cosign you know
it's like do we go with the miso base do
go with the Chipotle base do we go with
a habanero okay so this I actually have
a question of shares my least favorite
hot sauces are vinegar heavy mmm what
are the other things that can preserve a
hot sauce it's tough it's tough but that
what keeps it right right you know you
can do it with other options but then
sometimes you kind of like have a real
short shelf life on that hot sauce right
so it's one of those things where you
can find it or you can make it but you
kind of have to like eat it with the
meal or within like a couple weeks this
would go bad pretty great oh yeah that's
the preserve you know we're casting a
wide net with today's interview but the
fans they'd revolt if I didn't focus on
Modern Family for at least one way
journey who's your favorite celebrity
guest cameo favorite guest star one of
them was very recently with which was
Chris Martin who is just the sweetest
literally like where's the [ __ ] in your
armor sweet too sweet too sweet
yeah what are you hiding I thought he
was gonna try to steal the show from us
for something one of my favorites going
way back was Edward Norton we had done a
play together and the show was probably
in its second season but he came in and
did a very elaborate character we got to
improvise a lot just a lot of fun what
have you picked up working alongside
Sarah
Nolan Rico work ethic really the kids on
the show the kids on the show in a lot
of ways were more professional than the
adults from the very beginning because
they were raised in that world they knew
all the rules like the rules are just
sort of ingrained in them than all the
Union rules they always came prepared
you know the adults were sort of like
depending on schedule and stuff you know
like right various stages of preparation
which cast member is most like their
character in real life and that's it
yeah and it's kind of an inspirational
quality of no I'm not going to that
that's sort of Ed's tagline no I won't
be there I'm gonna stay at home
what's hot in Hawaii the volcanoes with
volcano in this I'm gonna start sweating
soon good I can't wait I know that's
happening what's that most anybody's
ever sweat
Joey Coco Diez I thought maybe gonna
we're gonna lose him Tom Arnold I was
like oh that's what's gonna take down
the show all right I'll see you see what
I can do about that all right I so we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that Graham where we do a
deep dive and I guess Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context but as we just talked about I
don't have an account which only throws
a wrench into our system but we figured
out a workaround what we've done is
pulled some of our favorite Tibor all
sports pictures so I'll show you the
picture oh my god
all right so this first one throwing out
the first pitch of the Mets game are you
nervous for this very very very very
nervous probably as a nervous as I've
ever been for anything because I'm sort
of a delusional athlete like I think I'm
a better athlete than I am so now it's
time to step up to the plate literally
not not quite literally I practiced and
did not throw strike the catcher who was
a gentleman by the name of John Buck as
it was coming in and going off target he
ran out and caught it and made it seem
like it was just part of his normal run
out to the mound to congratulate nice
little frames that you get he framed
exactly he did a very long term Franklin
and then pull it in and then came out
and shook my hand what do you remember
about playing on a high school
basketball team that set an Oregon state
record for the most consecutive losses
the guy who was there the night we broke
the streak was a professional weight
lifter and he came in and he gave a
speech and he said you guys can never
quit
I've never quit and then as we were on
our way out he was like and I've never
won a single weightlifting tournament
and we were running out onto the court
to try to break our record but somehow
it worked I guess we were like we don't
want to be that guy
I like to work around on Instagram
[Music]
that's good yeah I'm starting to really
I'm feeling that one mm-hmm yeah so
you've said that you went to graduate
school as a tactical means of avoiding
auditioning it's true and then while
it's not ditch-digging acting can be
tough because you have to kind of become
comfortable with rejection being a part
of everyday life do you remember your
first TV audition and if so was it the
humiliating experience that you always
expected it or feared it would be yep
it's funny you use that analogy because
I always say it's not taking Dutch to
because I actually did digged it for a
few weeks when I was in junior high and
it was the worst job of my life but the
humiliation can be incredible
one of my very first auditions I had two
weeks to work on this I was using a
British accent I'm not particularly
talented with accents but I worked
really hard on this accent and sitting
down in front of a just a big bank of
people intimidating people and the
casting director he whispers in my ear
oh yeah we're not using the accent so I
gave an audition trying to switch out of
a British accent into an American accent
on the fly that sounded like I was
having a stroke in front of all of these
people it was like that's where you land
mouth ma'am
madam I take it you didn't get the
callback I did no I did not even get
real like eye contact on my way
Asante picante dawson's is almost a
crisis right it flirts with crisis it
sorts with crisis I would agree yeah
it's good no so I know that you fell in
love with Salt Lake City almost 20 years
ago it's a place that you and Holly and
your kids call home search but as a
byproduct of Ashland Oregon I know that
the beaver State still holds a special
place in your heart so what I want to do
is give you a number of categories and
you can tell me which state reigns
supreme
Utah or Oregon's that's it yes national
parks Utah northern Utah is amazing too
but for very different reasons Southern
Utah's all the stuff you sort of see the
127 hours or old but it's really just an
incredible place to spend time it's
really easy to get to it's unlike
anything on earth that's sort of like
what I imagine Mars is like Sundance
Film Festival or the Oregon Shakespeare
Festival that's really tough I'm gonna
say the Oregon Shakespeare Festival
because it's even more of an anomaly
like a crazier thing that Shakespeare
Festival ended up such a huge successful
one and I say this with the fact that I
tried to get work there forever and they
never hired me so this how could this is
how they were smart enough to never hire
me so that I think puts them at the top
of the list do you have a take on this
whole self-service gas law in Oregon
because it seems to be tearing the state
apart at the seams I think it's us
trying to hold on to something that we
feel makes us interesting this is like
an idiosyncrasy it's like somebody you
know keeping their flip phone Clyde
Drexler her call him alone Traxler
that's not even close Malone is the
largest man in the history of human life
to fall down at somebody blowing on him
like he was such a flop or he a little
ahead of his time way ahead of his time
but I mean the guy could not have been
more stout to be full flying into chairs
and constantly sprawling out on the
floor we we had a real dislike for Karl
Malone in Oregon
now this was on your previous season
this one we can't move because it's the
face melter no not so if we took it out
I'd like to take it out as somebody
who's eaten at about a hundred times I
took a big bite of that
do you guys remember that time when yeah
oh boy
that's where [ __ ] gets real over the
years you've made more than your fair
share of red carpet best-dressed lists
and I'm curious from the outside looking
in how do you unpackage the relationship
between the celebrity and the celebrity
stylist in other words how much
influence do you have over your Golden
Globes fit and more importantly how much
do you care about it you know if I'm
being a hundred percent on us I'm sort
of The Dandy fob like I actually really
I dig it I don't want to be that guy
actually like I'm from Oregon I want to
be like a man's man but I just am NOT
you want to be the flannel pulp yeah
yeah even when I am actually camping I'm
like I should have thought way too much
I need to learn sign language to carry
this one home this one alright so this
next one is mad dog 357 with number nine
plutonium when we start getting into
scientific stuff I just feel like this
should be put into some sort of a
capsule the fuel something Elon Musk
this should be called Elon Musk
that hurts my lips yeah that makes my
lips hurt mm-hmm yeah it's first time
ever that my teeth have heard feel like
my teeth hurt welcome to the club so
Hollywood has a reputation for being
this dog-eat-dog place where the
[ __ ] win but you seem to have a more
grounded disposition a more low-key
lifestyle and I'm curious in what ways
has been the nice guy actually served to
help your career in la-la land and can
you give me one time where it is maybe a
detriment I'm always trying to reiterate
work really hard and you'll work if
you're talented and you work really hard
but that there's a certain element of
luck that gauges your career it's so
hard to think with the pain it's going
through my face um for whatever reason
I've never felt that I could control my
career I don't consider that like a
personality thing that I've made happen
I just feel lucky that I never felt that
way I think that the way it works is
when you get an opportunity if you just
exceed the expectations of whoever gave
you that opportunity then you'll get
another opportunity I totally agree I
totally agree it doesn't it doesn't
require all that other thought right
it's just that you you will get
opportunities and you just have to
absolutely throw yourself into them
completely
[Music]
and you don't even have control over how
well that thing does right like this is
this must be kind of a cool thing this
whole show for you right it's a glass
half-full glass everybody has a problem
they just want a problem solved so if
you can solve that problem yep then
they'll keep giving you problems solve
it all right time so you guys win in on
the last one so this is the last dab we
call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing okay you don't
have to if you don't want to but the
bottles already there okay so now I can
feel myself sweating mm-hmm
look great though this is the first time
I have to go back and and watch to see
if I've touched my nose but my nose
hurts and I've comfort my nose hurt from
hot sauce without touching we really
find your limits here I have once that's
not go I mean what's the extent of this
to your ears eventually hurt people like
my neck is stiff like my back hurts now
boys sleep well I haven't been there but
you know it's just it's limit it's not a
health aid it's not it's not why we do
this show all right all right ty
cheers my man Cheers
that's really good mm-hmm he's really
hot mm-hmm
I'm not just saying it because it's your
brand but it also tastes you can
actually taste it as well that's what we
tried to do you did it hot ones
all right time well now that you've
battled ten scorching hot chicken wings
on YouTube I just have one more hoop for
you to jump through all right it's been
written that you blink excessively when
you're stressed or excited and in season
two of our show
I had an epic staredown with Jay Pharoah
I lost and it has haunted me ever since
welcome to your so here now that I have
the low-hanging fruit in front of me I'm
going to try to avenge it it's no holds
bar on the count of three first to blink
loses one two three I feel so good I am
about to give you your first win in a
blinking contest and I need it so if I
win I'll never get out from under it yes
yes I needed that but you know what ty
Brown there are no losers today you
cleared the board you made it through
against all odds and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you my friend
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in you today is the day I became a man
well we already talked about the podcast
and our businesses in Salt Lake and Park
City so I would like to talk about kids
in the spotlight which provides funding
for foster kids to make their own films
and tell their own stories and so please
go to kiss ink dot org
[Music]
good job
I had a great time that's awesome that
really is literally this may be the most
masculine thing I've ever done I'm very
impressed
what it's worth hey what's going on
spice Lords and Sean Evans checking in
from a table by himself and you notice
something different no it's not a new
haircut the jacket you've seen it before
we have a new bottle of the last dab
Carolina Reaper Edition still got it
it's the last dab in the Carolina Reaper
together at last
a special edition pick it up while
supplies last Heaton is calm top your
bottle it's still a tough one